[Music]
guys I can't believe I have to make
another video I said I wasn't going to
make I become one of these youtubers now
guys I said I was gonna make another
video but something epic you Jobs have
it's something I think happened Big Ed
and roasts finally talked it out and it
is like a hair of my mom I got that's
that your hair boom ed Andros first of
all we're gonna play this clip latest
from TLC we're big and apologizes to his
daughter this is actually very important
clip for context later on in the video
so let's flip and watch it so what's up
well you're right
yeah it just kind of blew up on my face
I tried to warn you so for context here
Big Ed is 54 his daughter is 29 and the
girl he was dating Rhodes I ever wanted
to marry even is 23 I had to do it I had
to follow through you know I was upset
that her old enough to be her dad and I
was like what are you doing
23 oh she says what do you have in
common with her what actually I want to
think about that what what do they have
in common
what does Big Ed and Rose have in common
the has to be I can't think of anything
I can't think of a single thing maybe
the height they're almost the same
height she's a little taller cuz you
were blowing me off and essentially
saying a few like I don't I'm just gonna
do whatever I was selfish and I'm sorry
one thing that I definitely wanted you
to know is that you were and are and
have always been the love of my life ah
and we have such a great foundation and
I mean to be fair ed must have really
liked Rose if he's willing to cut
jeopardize his relationship with his
daughter just to meet up with this young
girl cross continent right everyone
question his motives but I still just
makes him a national anyways I'm like
dumbass I'm a human funny dumbass so
they make that so great that's so great
however however however OMA gross and
Big Ed are talking and it happened and
it's beautiful
oh my god I can't wait for this it's so
good explosive no Nick ed nice one
whoever reapply to this you were in the
Philippines you guys were able to
communicate well Rose why do you feel
like you need a translator now cuz she
man she mad as hell
[Applause]
she man she mad as hell
that's the feeling oh you're angry
you're angry right now
Oh Eddie it is scared look at him run a
facial recognition on that side 100%
terrified you should be I'm not sure but
how does that make you feel to hear Rose
say that I'm confused
okay look at ed sippin on that vows
water
he's sipping on that vod's living the
high life and I said nice immediately
when I got back from the Philippines we
facetimed a little bit but then the last
time was I think rosemary wasn't it
around Valentine's Day what Valentine's
Day they secretly hooked up question
mark I doubt it what happened on
Valentine's Day special
I didn't oh oh no one believes him where
are these the council the council have
spoken we do not believe a word single
word that big ad is a summary reached
out to me Rose is that true yeah is that
true Rose know what I believe Rose okay
but that's big I did sound like a lie no
Rose is that true he's the first to
message me okay I can show you the
messages I haven't he has the receipt
she reached out to me and I asked it's
because I don't want to be a rude I
replied to him want to be rude that's
why she was answering messages from Edie
she reached out to me she was so angry
with me why did she reach out to me on
February 9th does that look like she's
frustrated or she's angry at me you see
this photo here does I have proof that I
look angry to you oh you reached out to
me you wanted to start a relationship
again and wanted me back and wanted a
present for Valentine's Day
they said phase have discussed again the
classic she needs to copy writing for
Valentine's Day you wanted me to come
and see you and I was ready Shawn I was
ready I miss Rose I love rose I was
ready to give up everything my daughter
I was ready to give up my daughter
I had already repaired that relationship
with Tiffany but I had feelings for once
and I was ready to take that what so he
had this we did the clip we just saw
he's repairing the relationship but now
he's saying that after that he was
prepared to give up his relationship
with his daughter again
what the hell Edie T says but then I go
on your Facebook and I see a picture of
you
what is this what is this what is this
look at ed with all these evidence look
at this evidence it refutable evidence
what is this this is this M photo look
angry to you huh you and your girlfriend
what and you had told me that you don't
have a girlfriend and I can show you the
text it's right here what is this road
why is this so funny what is this route
please tell me what this is he came
prick he had them ready relationship
with even zooming in on the text ex
question mark yes that is a girl whoa
girl
since we are you now in a relationship
with a woman
[Music]
catch this after the next commercial
Brenda's kidding all right
the tech oh wow they really did it yeah
are you Broce huh are you dating her why
do they sell obtain about it they're
broken up who cares right what's the big
deal you broke up with Edie you started
a relationship with the woman yes so ed
did you know that rose was bisexual I
did I had no idea they look like very
you know pretty sick well there's the ED
with more receipts why is this so funny
I don't get it
look at these funny photos huh look at
these funny photos explain these all
right she reached out to me because she
had broken up with her girlfriend and
wanted me back everyone in a present for
Valentine's Day I want to know what Rose
is saying can I just have the translator
just tell me what is she saying right
now translate is like I don't know I
don't understand
I'd wanted to get back together and that
he was asking for a second chance no
good why oh then you say that already
it's just I'm confused about the
timeline here now let's bring in Ed's
daughter Tiffany who has been listening
into the house she has been listening
the whole time she's been old I'm she
heard a Tiffany party
I guess um so you heard your dad say he
was willing to give you up to have this
relation oh that's the face of a man who
no he AFT up god damn it ed I try to
give him chances main I try but he
doesn't learn what are you doing how did
that make you feel that I will be honest
I was pretty shocked to hear that right
now that when she reached out to him
again that he was willing to jeopardize
my relationship again and she found out
lime this is crazy
Oh I mean I'm his only daughter and he's
willing to you okay you're not making
that face anymore are you Eddie
huh you're not making that I guess I
messed up face Jesus Christ is our
relationship again for love which I want
I want to see him with somebody and not
alone but I mean I can't support it I
mean there's such a huge age gap there
but they don't have very much in common
I would argue nothing in common I would
say that I think this but then again you
don't have to have things in common for
a relationship to work
Tiffany I didn't mean I didn't mean it
like that yeah how do you how do you
mean it that it yeah we heard you
dumbass a million years I mean I
yeah mr. backpedal going backwards on
the back mr. back Beto going backwards
again
come on Ed stand up for yourself for one
stick to what you're saying using you I
was put every
on the wine and I'm sorry and I hope you
know I love you so much
yeah you already gave that speech yet
huh you remember that haven't happen in
the last video we already heard this how
many times how many times huh you never
learned you never learn you heard that
the people that love you eh I cannot
stand by Oh
tambour I wasn't gonna hit you at
Tamborine ashamed this early sorry
I was just following my heart I'm an
idiot I fell in love love does it makes
you do stupid things and it was a
mistake now I know it's a mistake and
I've learned my lesson I've learned my
lesson
no you didn't because he already been
through this
you ain't lunch ba you know nothing
you're praying Tiffany so this is your
first time talking to Rose right yep Oh
I mean Rose why what did you see in my
dad I mean did you really love him
because he really did love you because
he was willing to give me up don't get
at home with me please I'm just asking
you that's how she talked the whole time
but okay do you did you have true
feelings for him yes I believe her
because to be honest from from what I've
seen it mean it didn't really seem like
don't get a tone with me
someone just snapped I guess she doesn't
know what she said right away okay I can
tell Rose is very upset I'd like for the
translator to tell me what Rose is upset
about okay
Rose is saying that she feels that it
doesn't see or appreciate all the effort
that she did for for the relationship
and that what effort but Rose is playing
that is lying and trying to hide the
fact that he wasn't really a good person
to her but what about almost all the
secrets
what about all des secrets and maybe his
height which I'm not quite sure how how
you can't hide that considering you guys
would video chat and Skype but yeah it's
impossible to not see someone's height
from a video because I am actually 6
feet tall as you all know 611 actually
as you can tell because I am on camera
right now you can tell my height there's
no way for me to hide my height from you
guys because I'm on the simple things
that you should be honest about as far
as past relationships especially when
you're wanting him to call him what what
was he saying that she really doesn't
care about this oh my god and actually
asked her to go on video calls on
multiple times and even acceptable on
sex did you follow with him
really really sex video that Rose is
talking about we're going here the
council is waiting with full
anticipation what about the sex videos
what about them
see I think what matters here is when
they happen right if in a relationship
using that kind of stuff but I don't
think that's that weird when did it
happen
can you tell me is right I am so
confused what please
I'm saying it's a lie it's just a lie oh
my god
it's a lie even even his daughters
believe him he's like I kind of want
rose dad to come in live from the shower
hey come on come on back yet well shower
together again come on
it seems farad he thought it came on you
know was saying that during one call it
was asking why are you always sad and
Rose was saying well we have a lot of
problems here and so ed said well make
it now and I will pay you get naked in
front of me do it now and I will send
you money oh my god how do you make this
up how do you come up with these ideas
making up stuff that's ridiculous come
on
Wow okay oh and the council seems to
agree with Rose
interesting I'm so confused believe
let's talk about you know some of the
things that you you were accused of no
no no brush-off over that I want to know
more come on Ed has everything on his
phone he has all the logs I need to know
he has all the happy faces has all the
sad faces he has all the angry faces
come on so they show all the clips
actually I never saw the myford thing he
gave her much really cute toothbrush a
cute
this your breath is not pretty I love
you I love you I love you so first of
all I don't think I was wrong in asking
alright it's the same answer I don't
care when you were asking rose to shave
her legs
I love the daughter frenching I
apologize for asking you to shave your
legs but let me explain women in
California they laser their legs so I
don't know how I feel about this it's
obviously very rude and presumptuous
that a woman should just change the way
you prefer them but I feel like in a
relationship if you like certain things
about another person I think you have
the right to it ask and I expect them to
ask me to do the same kind of thing
right I wouldn't demand it and I
wouldn't be angry if they didn't want to
do it I don't have this kind of probably
my dad okay cuz she's perfect
but I don't think is that crazy I think
it's all the things stacked up though he
has for this D test yes for shaving
likes your breast things and all this
stuff it's all came on once at a time
and it just comes off more as all you
need to change if you're gonna be with
me kinda that's not cool obviously we
understand what I'm making here they
argument okay cool
it was something that I wasn't familiar
with but I apologize I apologize I did
give him a hard time but it did weird me
out I'm gonna be totally honest it was
weird but I apologize if I hurt you for
asking you to do that that was not my
intention
this is getting way heavier it's not
trying to make myself look good and make
you look bad I threw my own natural
ability I made a fool out of myself huh
god damn it's pretty embarrassing to
have your personal hygiene per se out in
the public see that's the thing yeah I
totally get that couldn't he have wait
to be out of camera site right they made
a whole thing about it I don't
understand what she's talking about
she's Olli they needs to feel real it's
an eye on you and she's queen I
understand she's standing up for Rosa
but what the is she saying this is
not an argument I feel like no woman was
ever good enough for big yet he always
has to find something wrong with him and
also like right after they met he put
all these things on her too that is
definitely not help either where do you
come from you're not part of the council
I understand that I know but I have
trust issues
she wasn't being honest with me I had
the right to ask and she has trust
issues that's ironic why don't you tell
her before you enter that you know what
kids yes yes yes it's wrong raising kids
in America's you know you have two
beautiful daughters they're expensive
they cost money do you feel as though
like throughout your life you've had a
problem with relying information
correctly of course I have I'm not
saying it's right I'm not saying I'm
perfect but another council member
speech are you gonna tell me that you
genuinely love rose yes I did love her
why is rose saying that you used her
that's what I want to know that's your
prerogative yeah definitely not think
this whole thing would blow up in his
face it seems like oh I'm meeting this
girl I might owe and I get to get famous
in the process I don't think it was like
going in into one of these things
completely he was thinking he could get
all of it
I can get famous so I can get this oh
wait people realize I have a really ugly
personality I like to believe that
people can change because otherwise
what's the point we're just gonna tear
each other down constantly over and over
and over again even though maybe my
hopes are not so high for it but who
knows what will happen in the future
another episode but I believe for once
and for all
this is the conclusion of the big Edie
and Rose saga thank you for watching the
follow up hit like if you enjoyed
subscribe for more epic videos become
member thank you guys so much it's been
great I love that we made a sub
community on this channel now really fun
stuff thanks for joining and I see you
guys next time
Hado
[Music]
energy
Chico
exclusively at gmail.com